[Music]
prince william and kate middleton
celebrate their 10-year wedding
anniversary with a rare home video
the couple tied the knot in a massive
ceremony at westminster abbey in 2011
and on thursday kensington palace shared
a touching video of william and kate
along with their three children
seven-year-old prince george
five-year-old princess charlotte and
three-year-old prince louis
near the family's home in norfolk
england
[Music]
the love birds captioned the sweet clip
quote thank you to everyone for the kind
messages on our wedding anniversary
we are enormously grateful for the 10
years of support we have received in our
lives as a family
w and c the timing is right now so very
happy
on wednesday the palace released two new
portraits to commemorate the milestone
one taken outside kensington palace
earlier this week by chris floyd
features the duke and duchess of
cambridge holding hands and sporting
matching blue ensembles kate in a light
blue dress
william in a blue sweater over matching
slacks
the caption 10 years and
that that's the second portrait
featuring the two in a sweet embrace
on thursday william's grandmother queen
elizabeth dedicated
instagram and twitter post to the couple
sharing throwback pics from their
wedding day alongside the caption quote
wishing the duke and duchess of
cambridge a very happy wedding
anniversary
e.t ken also confirmed that prince harry
and meghan markle privately
congratulated prince william
and kate on their milestone anniversary
which comes on the heels of a reported
falling out between the brothers after
harry and megan's bombshell interview
with oprah winfrey
i think the idea of seeing this reprisal
of the fab four
harry and megan william and kate is
really
so far down the future it's almost quite
hard to even
envisage it at the moment so much has
happened
there is so much hurt on either side i
think the first step
is william and harry getting the
relationship back on track
and then we will have to see i know it
was always harry's intention
that his children would be close to
william and kate's children he wanted
them to grow up close
as families but back to william and kate
on tuesday
the duchess tried her hand at golf while
her hubby and a group of new friends
cheered her on at the cheesy waffles
project she may have lifted on her first
swing but she
nailed it on her second
whether they're playing sports for a
good cause or spending time with their
kids by the beach
we can't get enough of this adorable
couple congrats on the milestone
[Music]
anniversary